Well, I think we'll begin now.
Good evening, everyone.
Good to be back with you.
Before I begin, Bunty asked if you'd be interested in a Zoom meeting tomorrow at 11.
You may not be free, you know, it's late notice, but if you could let me know.
And...
You could, I suppose, put a message here just to say yes or no, or if you need to think about it, just send an email.
And then I can contact Bunty this evening.
Well, it doesn't look as if we're going to have many more.
I've been thinking about the situation with getting back to the idea of the space between
the way space has been created in between people within society.
And there's a little thing you could do with the hands, you may know this, and I was thinking that it was rather a good representation of what's happened.
Taking an individual as a kind of micro,
representation of society and taking a couple of polarities doing a mock-up in an individual's body of what's happened by separating two polarities in the body and then watching what happens
And there's a little game with the hands.
What you do is you clasp your hands like if you could do this.
You may know this.
You clasp your hands as if in prayer.
Okay.
And you extend your two index fingers like that.
And you press them close together.
Keep them pressed quite firmly.
Don't hurt yourself, but keep them pressed firmly.
Now, what I want you to do is to count to five and then suddenly open them and then open those fingers.
Don't stop clasping your hands.
Just open those fingers so they're apart and then just watch the fingers.
Don't do anything.
Just watch the fingers.
So I'm going to count one, two, three, four, five, open.
I just watched your fingers.
see so if you suddenly separate polarities what happens that have been used to being close is exactly that but the the renewed contact is different isn't it it's more sensitive
and i thought it was a good representation you know in one one person of society and what the the state we're in so um i i'm presenting it really as an optimistic uh uh view of things you know hoping that this will be a experience very much across society that people will they will form different relationships a different quality relationship
you know, that will be fruitful, more sharing, more sensitive, more appreciative of each other.
Because there are big changes taking place.
And if we go back to the 19th century, 1865 in Japan, there were big changes taking place there.
with the restoration of the monarchy.
And also it was the year that Dr. Usui Mikawa was born.
He came from an old samurai family.
And they were very privileged because they were, you know, they served the shogun, a powerful, powerful people.
So they lived privileged lives.
and um of course that gradually disappeared usui as a child was still though sent to martial arts school and he was a martial artist and um he was the same school that
um yoshiba went to the the founder of aikido and of course one founded the a new style that was aikido's got a very strong spiritual um uh kind of protocol and philosophy to it you know you you don't you don't kill it you don't go in for the kill in other words um so it's it's um
It has that spiritual quality.
And of course, Usui founded Reiki.
But before he did that, of course, he was very much involved with Tendai Buddhism.
He was involved also with the esoteric sect of Tendai Buddhism.
He was very, very devout.
And he was...
also connected to the Yamabushi.
They were a mountain group.
They used to meditate and fast in the mountains.
And that's what he would do sometimes.
And in 1922, he was doing exactly that.
And he had, as the story goes, he had this vision, this kind of, you know, it was a road to Damascus type of experience.
and as a result he founded a kind of teaching that that brought a lot of the esoteric traditions to the ordinary people which would it would involve certain exercises and certain you know ways of enhancing one's spiritual life and he became an able doctor
he didn't go in for healing he didn't think of himself as a healer but of course the um the the um yamabushi actually did have they had healing practices that and he would have been connected to that so these influences were in place um but the thing that strikes me about
about this person who was obviously so very spiritual isn't so much it isn't the the legend of you know visions on the mountain but it's the fact that he was known to be um good to be with
you know, people felt good after they'd been with him.
They came away feeling better and yet feel physically better.
And gradually,
a healing practice sort of developed from this and he developed a system that was designed for self-healing it really started with self-healing or so the the commentaries go that obviously there's a lot of different versions but and this was for the the military
and so you know it meant that they had to hand the first aid before you know sometimes of course in warfare you you know you can't get help and there are stories of people who've i heard one recently of someone who just did the legs were more or less blown blown off i mean they certainly finished without without the particular person you know that this story uh was about i think was uh during the in afghanistan and um
He was passing out, you know, just with the sheer trauma of the experience.
And he remembered some breathing had been shown.
It was just a simple count.
And he was able to stop himself because of doing this breath and help his men and call for help.
And he was saved and the men were saved.
He lost his legs, but he could have lost his life.
But he remembered the breathing.
anything to do with reiki but it's just to do with the fact that if you have to hand very simple tools that just as knowledge without anything else you know that breathing or some of these techniques that the reiki techniques for instance if
My first experience was probably when I was at the festival hall and I had some musicians in the room at the back where the musicians gather.
And they're heavy doors because they have to be soundproof.
And I went to see them at the end just to speak to them.
And I said, oh, hello.
I remember making an exclamation because there was somebody who came out who I didn't know.
And my hand was in the hinge door.
It's a big, heavy door.
And bang, you know.
Blood everywhere.
And I immediately applied Reiki.
No pain.
No bruise.
No swelling.
We're talking about a severely trapped hand.
I lost the nail.
The nail did fall out, but there was no bruise, no swelling, no pain.
So you see, in a trauma, first aid of that nature can be very, very useful.
And it was certainly to me.
So anyway, he formulated this system
um of self-healing and eventually healing other people um and it had and still does have five strands to it um one is gokai which is the um the precepts just for today i i will be thankful
etc and the other of course is a blessing which which we've heard um he didn't do that blessing that's nothing to do with usui it's just that in the context um of doing this over the over the internet of course it's it's really good that we have a monk that can just do a blessing i mean i can tell you more about the what became an attunement later it was developed more in the west i think and supposed to be
based around a right in in the esoteric tendai school called goshimbo which is means dharma protection for the body and it was just a kind of vigorous choreographed movement around the initiate but really it's very little connected with that and it involves more symbols and mantras
symbols that you draw with the hands and so you know i mean i know all these and i i do use them because i've been shown them but um um anyway that is um one of one of the um the the ways that um
blessings are done but we're very lucky to have had the Bajanga Sutta and then of course is the the Hatsurei Reo which are the energy exercises and then there's Tenehira which is the palm healing palm healing is not it isn't
It isn't just Reiki that uses that.
I think there was a time when they had the nurses doing it in America as a kind of experiment because the hands are very, they're great comforter's hands.
What do you do when you comfort?
Your hands go to the shoulder or around their shoulders.
um you know this is what happens or you hold somebody what do we do when somebody's do you hold down you know so it is the nature of hands to um give off this kind of healing uh comforting uh effect and then of course there's there are the mantras and symbols that are mentioned that are used in the blessing but mantras and symbols
also um are used in in healing but you know the symbols are they're constructs they mean what we want them to mean i mean they what i mean is that the the actual value of them is what we give to them i have a friend who um
he said to he he taught the piano and what he was teaching a student some beta and this said to him he said he was a challenging student how do you know beethoven wanted to be played like this and he said it's the kind of friend that always makes makes one smile he said because my teacher tell me
and my teacher's teacher told him and her teacher's teacher told her and his teacher's teacher was told by beethoven it's that sort of thing and very impressive well we all know we can do this we can all always connect and i mean i i i too connect to bateman in that way we can all connect to people call me but
it's taking if you take the trouble to find out the the chains the link sorry the links in the chain it becomes meaningful then and if it's important to you it becomes meaningful
and then if you if you tell people that it becomes even more meaningful you know even though people know i mean you know we can all connect to each other we are all so very very connected in spite of the space between you could make double the space between we would remain connected you won't stop it you see so we're connected in many different ways so
Anyway, that gives you a bit of info about Reiki.
I wasn't really looking forward to doing that.
I find history a bit tedious.
But I mean, it's how you tell it, isn't it?
It's like jokes.
It's like humour.
What we're going to do now is we're going to do just a bit of breathing.
You don't have to stand up.
The breathing exercises, they are exercises.
They're not really meditations, but you can use them.
I'm talking about the pranayama things we did.
And I do feel very strongly about this idea of allowing the breath to shape the body and to shape the posture.
Okay.
I have some lovely suggestions from...
I'm terribly sorry, it's Dan, somebody, I think.
I can't remember, but it was a suggestion about breathing.
And one was, you know, just to breathe, just take an ordinary breath and look for the calm between the breaths.
It's lovely.
I mean, I'd certainly do that.
I'll probably do that.
It's a nice technique.
It's a good technique.
And if you have any ideas, techniques that you want to share, because now is the time to share.
It's the time for ideas to be shared.
We tend to take ownership of things, don't we?
That's my idea.
In a way, we do that more with ideas than we do objects.
And I'm not thinking of the idea of a kind of cooperative sharing.
but just a non-ownership sharing where there's an awareness that we don't own anything.
I mean, there's nothing I've shown you.
I mean, there are things, some of those things are things that I've evolved with me, but they don't belong to me really.
I could write a symphony, it wouldn't not belong to me.
You'd find so much there belonging to other people.
And the same with those other people, you know.
So it's a way of looking at the interconnectedness of things.
It's a way of looking at polarities, at spaces, and feeling the energy of them.
there is a another point that i want to make about the breathing and that the the pranayama breaths and it is that they are meant also as a tool you can do them as exercises every day or you know you can count or whatever or just use that breath and do it for longer periods of time you know gradually build up you know
So the idea isn't that you breathe all day like that at all.
It is an exercise.
But days are stressful.
So, I mean, before I come on here, I do some breathing exercises because, you know,
There's always a bit of a buzz, isn't there?
The energy, you need energy to do things like this and you don't want to fall on your face.
So there are breathing exercises.
Well, one for instance, the simplest is four, four, four, four.
So rhythm is very good.
It's very good.
As long as it doesn't become stressful where you're holding your breath until you're passing out.
um so four four four four would be breathing into four three four hold for four out for four and the last bit for four if you like the clenching and then again one three four hold out two three
It's calming and you're taking control.
So if your heart's beating fast, breathing, it's good.
But you have to do a fair amount to keep at it, keep in control, and the breath will control it.
One that's good for increasing the vagus tone.
And of course, the vagus runs right from the top here, right down into the gut.
Very powerful nerve.
And one that's used, there's various ones you'll find and that are given if you research it, is the 528, the 528.
okay so we'll try this and don't worry too much about about all the details of what i showed you yesterday remember the stomach remember to allow the breath you know feel just feel a slight you know shaping of the lumbar region and let it go a bit further i mean that that's fine
we want to avoid this, this kind of thing.
You know, I even do it when I'm, when I'm trying to explain it, I will find myself doing that because we're taking it apart, aren't we?
And it becomes more complicated when you take things apart, but it isn't really, it's just, if you remember the expansion of the stomach and let the breath take over, that will be good.
So we're going to do five,
two eight okay so after two one two one four five hold two out two three four five six always good seven eight in two three
Hold.
Two.
Out.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
Eight.
In.
Two.
Three.
Hold.
Two.
Out.
Three.
Four.
And if you do that, it will calm you and keep you more in the chill-out system, keep you chilled, keep you cool.
But there's another I would like to...
mentioned this i resisted this there's another way of using breath another technique and it i'm sure you've all seen it and heard about it and you might do it i hope you do but of course it's the um alternate nostril breathing now you're supposed to put two things here and you block you block the right nostril yeah and then you breathe five times right in and out
three four five now and then you put your ring finger there okay the other nostril now one
Three.
Four.
Five.
Now, it's tremendous.
You get a great feeling of balance.
I don't know what it is about it, but you start the day with that.
If you do about nine in one each nostril, that's fine.
I do three different ones where you breathe in one nostril and out through the other.
Now, if you find one side is blocked,
What you do is give just a bit of pressure.
Say if it's that side, my left side, then a bit of pressure under the right.
So the lymph nodes.
So you've got a bit of pressure there.
I mean, not too much for too long, but what it does for some reason
is loosened up on the other side.
So if that's blocked, you put your arm under there.
And if you can lie with a bit of pressure on it, not for prolonged periods, you don't want to cut off your blood supply, but it's good and it balances the body in a very good way.
i have a funny story about this because i i do this breathing on a train and that it's discreet you know you don't but when it comes to alternate nostril breathing yeah so what i'd do i'd sort of lean on one one and and and then lean maybe lean on the other but it became evident
it became evident that some people, they'd look at me and say, you're right mate.
Obviously they thought that I was making a kind of comment about their body odour or something, I don't know, but I decided to stop it.
But I thought, well, it's a pity I can't do that.
And I found myself imagining
that I was breathing through one nostril.
I want you to try this, actually.
I want to see if you find the same thing.
That's very interesting, right?
I've blocked my nostrils now.
I don't know about you.
But anyway, if you breathe, let's say through the left nostril, if you imagine that you're breathing just through here.
All right, let's just try it.
Now imagine you're breathing through the other nostril.
Right.
No, I don't know what you're experiencing.
And I mean, it's not like the, you know, the holding the breath thing when we were doing the finger game where I was pretty sure most people will be holding their breath.
This is different.
I mean, I was trying not to offend people and get myself into trouble.
And so I then found myself trying that now.
it's like to me it's it feels like i'm breathing through only one nostril it's the all the attention is there so all the sensations that you're focused on i hear uh feeling there whether you feel that but the the what i found quite fascinating this has happened a number of times where you stumble on something and then you find that it's actually done and it's done in certainly in the version i heard of uh yoga nidra
now nidra yoga is the sleep yoga or dream yoga and there's a very very excellent guided yoga nidra record done by sacred acoustics
it's really good it's very well crafted um particularly that you get a long version and a short version the short version i really like it it's it's it's quite beautiful and it takes you a guy you lie down it's great no effort you just and you go down to the throat then out to the joint there then the joint there then the wrist joint then there and then then you go back again then you're the other side and then gradually you go back
you know down to the the lower part of the body and do the same with the legs and then come back and you finish up there in the end and it's actually i think it's in the long version where they they they do this alternate nostril breathing with the imagination and except you you i think you breathe you breathe in and out quite a lot through one nostril or you keep alternating i can't remember now
because i tend to listen to the short version so it already exists well worth the thing to uh to try because you you you can really space out and and you've got this um what do you call it binaural rhythms um you know i'm not quite sure about binaural rhythms but it's the sort of thing i'd love to discuss with you because i i know you that you'd have opinions about it
Um, so that's the breath.
And don't forget with the breathing for Reiki, you breathe in through the nose.
That's all you need to remember.
You don't have to, you know, do great full breaths, you know, as, as in the exercises we've been doing in through the nose with the tongue on the roof and then out.
Okay.
Now we're going to do, um,
exercises now i want to show you something now that if anything else take this with you uh as far as the ex the reiki exercises go it's it's very good it's it's a beautiful exercise what we've done so far just to remind you is we've done the reiki shower which you can do the short version where you just scoop up the energy imagine you're scooping up energy
on the in breath and then down okay on the out breath and the more and you just a few times like that you know when you need to or or even if you just imagine you're doing it you you'll find you can get through it it doesn't affect i don't think it affects you immediately but after a few minutes you suddenly yeah i seem to be i seem to seem to be carrying on now with a i mean it won't suddenly make you into superwoman or superman but it will get you through
Well worth doing.
And then the other one is the inner cleansing.
The inner cleansing I really like.
So you pull it down.
I like some of the imagery that Bunty uses and the way you talked about it.
Wonderful stuff.
And I like the way he spoke of a kind of shaft of light coming down.
It's great.
So that might help actually in this way.
You pull the energy down into the stomach.
and it goes out, before you start breathing out, you think of it just beginning to go, and then you breathe out, and you begin to, you feel it going out through the skin and forming a balloon.
Now, teachers, well-known teachers, you know, commentators who have written lots of books about this will use that straightaway.
Others say, there are some who say, well, yeah, that's fine, but before you do that,
For six months, you should do this one.
And I'll tell you what it is.
You breathe.
It's the same.
You pull the energy down into the heart, the gut.
Again, it starts to spread.
But then just the fingertips, fingers and toes, fingers and toes, you can feel it coming out.
It does make them tingle quite a lot, that exercise, actually.
You breathe in.
freely going out and breathe out.
And now the polarity now are the extremities.
So think of the toes and the fingers.
It always works.
It's wonderful.
So those are the two exercises.
In the pack, there's an exercise called dry bathing.
And you imitate bathing, you know, you breathe in, breathe out.
Sorry, you go across the body first, right?
That side, then that side.
Read it.
It's supposed to be used before other exercises.
I prefer the Reiki shower.
It's simple.
I do the dry bathing.
But it's partly because I was shown it, you know.
The Reiki shower is over the whole body and it's...
It's simple to remember.
Read the dry bathing exercise and see if you might take to it.
But the three diamonds is the one that I would really like you to take away with you.
The three diamonds.
I always associate it with the triple gem.
Buddhism the triple gem of course being the Buddha the Dharma and the Sangha but it's likened to a diamond in that it's it's something that is very very clear beautiful polished we think of the diamonds being something polished and it but it also cuts through anything you know it'll cut through anything
and that of course research it it refers to the idea of cutting through i don't know uh dualistic thinking or you know concepts getting to the heart of a problem to the essence of things and you do it in you can do this sitting down there's no reason why you shouldn't do this sitting down or standing uh with the feet shoulder width apart but first of all
right you know you're what you're going to do so you take up the position all right this is our position we're sitting and then don't forget the eyes forwards half closed yeah so it turns turns makes us just a bit sleepy and receptive and then bring your attention to the horror
and then raise hands in gasha and then we lower the hands and we start the first part this is in three parts this imagine as you breathe in that you're pulling up energy from deep in the earth right up into the gut okay right so you breathe in through the nose tongue on the roof of the mouth
into the gut now hold that idea the image between that polarity deep in the earth and you and your stomach as you breathe out then again you simply keep that as a as a fixed image and out three times and out four times
five, six, seven, eight,
Now the second part, you breathe in again nine times and what you do is you imagine a sphere floating down.
If you can't, actually that sometimes helps you to get a sensory kind of foothold.
If you can't, just think of that
uh polarity and then this polarity okay so you breathe from here really the the first the first fixed attention is really on the horror because that's where it's going okay but if you can develop that image then then you would you would use it make it easy don't never try to visualize in a in a ferociously concentrated way just
pull that sphere of energy down as you breathe in or just think of your your heart just think of your belly and now and now think of your crown it's floating back to your crown this is sky energy we're pulling it up from the sky in fact you can think of the sky and then back again it floats back
Pull it down from the sky or the crown.
To the horror and out again.
I think that's three right now.
Four.
Five.
Six.
eight nine and then what we do the last one is the heart energy the heart energy
and you make as if holding a tree okay now just take a breath before we start the uh cycle of breath just breathe in and breathe out and just bring your hands down towards the ground okay now breathe in from the earth imagine it coming up from the earth
down from the sky and then bring your hands around i don't know whether you can see i this is not this is one that is a bit bit so it they're out and the palms are facing out and you give from the heart okay and bring back to where you started and the last bit of air out then second time up from the earth from the sky bring them around and give out
from the heart and then down again.
I'm going to call that three.
Now we say four down and then breathe in.
right i've decided that that is six okay now seven and down now eight down and nine okay now um you could substitute the the heart one
you could substitute the heart one for, um, an exercise that's, that's, um, given to us by the Heart Math Institute.
Um, they studied the heart.
They have been since, uh, 1991.
Yeah.
1991.
That's when a lot of research was done into the heart.
The heart, the heart forms before the brain.
and it calls the shots this is the thing it doesn't seem to does it but the heart has a lot of intelligence it just doesn't use words to express the intelligence and we don't listen to it when we should either so the heart the first thing is you breathe you breathe just imagine breathing
into your chest and out that is the actual portal you know for the breath to enter in and out and then if you can produce an elevated emotion what what is that
it's something that makes you feel good.
You know, I'm not thinking of a, you know, the kind of elevated emotion that comes from a mystical experience really.
But, but I don't know.
I think of my parents, I had beautiful parents and they've long gone.
And when I think of they were, I was so blessed.
They're beautiful people.
If I think of them, our family dog,
I go around, she didn't see me now, but when she does, she doesn't look pleased.
She explodes with joy.
Now that gives me, you may not like dogs, I'm sorry if you don't, but it gives me, it's indescribable.
I feel wonderful.
And sometimes she'll just sit under my legs.
I sit on the wall outside.
She doesn't know about distancing.
And she sits there and I look into her eyes and,
the message is this is where i want to be it's very beautiful and you can collect gems like that you remember the one last night the tears of my laughter flow like a stream into a dry desert and here's another one sitting in a train and listening to there's a parents behind me with a with a baby the baby wasn't making a sound
But the thing is that we're both singing to the baby.
And what made it beautiful for me was the fact that the guy didn't know the words.
I don't know why that made it beautiful, but he didn't know the words.
He was constantly missing words and trying to catch up in the song.
And the second thing was that the baby did not need pacifying.
Not at all.
She was perfectly happy without being sanctioned.
You could see that.
they sang to that baby because out of sheer love and that that's a gem and you can collect these and they don't all have to be sort of i don't know some people might find those things sort of soppy um well okay that's a that's all right as well but the point is that you can build up a treasure trove of these these things this is where memory instead of becoming the machine
of anger and regrets and shame and remorse it becomes you use it to build your kind of aladdin's cave with these memories
i i'd love it if you could share some you know anything you find that elevates so you you place this memory here and as you breathe out you give it to the world you see so it's the quality the frequencies the resonance of of your heart breathing right um i'd like you all to put your hands now in gasha
And with me, you can just think it if you like.
Okay, I can't hear you, so just for today, okay?
And we do it three times.
You'll find it on your sheets.
Just listen to me anyway, if you can't quite remember.
It's very simple.
Right.
Just for today, I will be thankful.
Just for today, I'll be free from anger and fear.
Just for today I will be honest and kind.
Just for today I will be thankful.
Just for today I will be free from anger and fear.
Just for today I will be honest and kind.
Just for today I will be thankful.
Just for today I will be free from anger and fear.
Just for today I will be honest and kind.
now we wait let's just rub our hands
think of the left hand think of the right hand left hand right hand left palm right palm left palm right palm now if you haven't got your shoes off i haven't i've got my slippers on i'm kicking them off here it doesn't matter if you can't energy likes it likes these little kind of hollows in the body likes to nestle in them
left part uh left um what you call that for the arch yes it's the left arch right think of the left arch of your foot now the right now the left arch now the right the left arch now the right now go to your right palm right palm
left palm left arch right arch right palm left palm left arch right arch of the foot now we're going to go around in a circle right
Here, enter here, then left foot, right foot.
Get the circle going.
It's a circle of energy.
Feel it going around.
Just feel it going around now.
We've got a circle going.
Can you feel that going?
I think some of you can actually.
okay now just slow it down now the left arch now the right palm the left palm the right arch with a figure of eight left foot right palm left palm
right arch left arch and up now get the figure of eight going okay now it can move as fast as thought and there's no other thing that has moved as fast as thought it's it's i think it's the fastest thing on the planet isn't it i don't know and and and like a train stopping
Okay.
Lie down.
If you can find a place to lie down, please.
And if you lie down and just think, try to invite the energy.
Try to feel, get that sense of allowing.
May all beings be happy and safe.
may all beings be happy and safe may all beings be happy and safe and then if you lift your your hands just to your your brow between the eyes and just silently
Ask the energy to flow freely for your highest and greatest good and for the highest and greatest good of all those whose lives you touch.
May the energy of Reiki flow freely for my highest and greatest good and for the highest and greatest good of all those whose lives I touch.
And then a third touch.
May the energy of Reiki flow freely for my highest and greatest good and the highest and greatest good of all those whose lives I touch.
Now we breathe in.
Place the hands over the eyes gently, just touching gently.
And
I want you to just do a couple of breaths of inner cleansing just to kind of clear away any distractions.
Breathe in.
Send the energy out.
In fact, you can send it to your fingers and your toes.
Care.
know that you're a very special important person creative an amazing machine with infinite possibilities feel a sense of tenderness you are the child you are the child no less
Now relax your hands and imagine them floating away.
Don't move consciously.
Just think of your hands.
Imagine them floating off your skin.
As soon as you relax, they will do it.
Now move them to the side of your head.
You can put them over your ears if you prefer.
Take a good breath.
Send the energy out.
Allow it.
Let me see you breathe.
Allow it to go to your fingers and your feet.
And feel it in your hands tingling.
Imagine your hands floating.
Just relax them.
Only think of them floating off your skin and feel the space between.
Sense the space between.
It's alive.
Now gently move your hands to the back of your head.
One higher than the other, as if you're resting your head, you know, in bed on the pillow with your hands behind you, but not on top of each other.
Fingers close.
now imagine your fingers floating away well of course if you're lying down you can't do that obviously i'm sitting up you see so just gently let them slide down towards the front of the neck until the heels of your hands meet so it's like a cup rest kind of
a little a golfer's seat you know with a spike so this covers the around the throat
Imagine your hands gently relaxing from there and leaving that area.
Now you put them on your chest with fingers close together and fingers pointing in towards each other and it would be the middle fingers would be touching.
okay now just to get rid of any distractions that might have got in the way let's do an inner cleansing breathe in and as you breathe out to let the uh polarity be your fingertips and your and your toes breathing fingertips and the toes
Bring your tips and toes.
Love your heart.
We're talking about an electromagnetic field that is not just a bit more than the brains.
We're talking a few thousand, you know.
It has a very big electromagnetic field.
Now down to the lower part where the, you know, the bottom of the sternum.
That little novel there where the thymus would be.
You know when a child is distressed,
When a child is distressed and the parent, they put their hand on the child and just cuddle them and say, it's going to be all right, it's going to be all right.
That is the relationship now between you and your body.
You and yourself, if you like, how it's, you don't have to overthink it, just treat yourself as you would treat a child.
It's going to be okay.
Now gently slide the hands down towards the inguinal fold, covering the lower part of the abdomen and pointing down towards the base energy centre, towards the genitals.
i want you to put one hand over your stomach over the horror any hand another hand on your forehead there's no past there is no future
There is now.
There is no anger.
There is no fear.
There is gratitude.
Now bring your hand down from your forehead and put it over the other one.
Now cross your hands like a brothers, like a St. Andrew's cross, you know, with one hand pointing to the opposite shoulder diagonally.
Feel gratitude.
and the love for the healing energy of compassion.
Wiggle your toes and roll your shoulders a bit and take your hands away.
Hands can gash out.
I give thanks for the healing energy of Reiki I give thanks for the healing energy of Reiki I give thanks for the healing energy of Reiki
All right.
Sorry, we overrun a bit, but we had a bit of a slow kind of start.
It doesn't bother me, by the way.
I'm not worried.
But before you go, I should give you time to blink a bit, shouldn't I?
I've been sitting, you see, but I suppose most of you have been.
You can do this sitting, of course.
We would have spent a bit of time on any parts of the body that you were concerned about.
It's just that we're a bit late.
Could you make it known if you'd like to manage an 11 o'clock Zoom tomorrow, if you can?
I don't know whether...
If you put, if you could type in yes or no or something here, then I'll know now rather than say, send me an email.
Okay.
Are they coming?
Yeah.
Okay.
Jackie, Krish, Krish, okay now.
Oh, Krish, you've put sound had gone.
Oh, so you haven't managed to get onto the Zoom, Krish?
You might, yeah.
That's 11 o'clock in the morning, okay.
Well, look, I tell you what, why don't we just have one anyway?
For those who can't come, do send me an email, any questions you have, okay?
If you can't make the 11 o'clock one.
I don't know why I can feel your energy, but it's quite extraordinary.
I could feel it during the day today.
It's a new one.
This is a new thing.
It looks as if I've got about 100 in the class, but I think it's people just sending messages.
I'm going to go now.
And you've been a lovely, lovely class.
And sleep well.
Metta.
Breathe well.
And love yourself.
Okay.